what was a good memory from hocus pocus
and how is it like to work with that uh
i've been a big fan of bette midler's
before the movie filmed she was on a hot
streak at that in the 90s there with
outrageous fortune and and down and out
in beverly hills and big business one
movie after no one hit after another and
her huge recording career i'm on my way
to work my first day on hocus pocus and
what do i hear on the radio from a
distance
one of her huge hits
i work with her that night
she was delightful and goofy and uh and
uh hilarious and she had those buck
teeth in his winifred and no eyebrows
and so it was hard to keep the giggles
from coming
while looking at her that close
and she was so so sweet and on the way
home on the car radio i heard uh you are
the wind beneath my wings like she's
huge
yeah so it was lovely uh and then
reconnecting with her recently i just
did hocus pocus 2 which is coming out on
hocus pocus too he was coming out on
disney did you just play the same
character i did billy i reprise billy
billy butchers butcherson uh right and
so the four of us immortals from the
first movie are the ones that came back
for hocus pocus
with a bunch of new kids 29 years
later i don't know how many sequels get
made 29 years after the first year
but to have all four of us back and
looking almost exactly the same as we
did almost 30 years ago holy [ __ ] yeah
the the ladies all looked fantastic
uh and um
and i i looked ex i looked like like
seconds had passed
because um
uh in 29 years because i was wearing a
prosthetic you know yeah
and you didn't get fat
with exactly the same weight exactly the
same build as i was 29 years ago so uh
it looked
freakishly the same and it was the same
wig from the first movie that was it the
wig had been sitting on remember the on
display at someone's creature shop and
they just took it off and put it back on
me exactly this and the fit pro it
didn't shrink nothing nothing
everything's the same